- I actually made a virtual
lunch date with someone
and our times got screwed
up because he's in London.
And anyway, maybe you won't
mind if I just talk with him
quickly now because I love him,
and I've been looking forward
to this moment for a while.
I think you might know him
if you live on planet Earth.
He was in some movies
like, "Devil Wears Prada"
and "The Hunger Games,"
many movies.
And his new book is called
"Taste My Life Through Food".
Stanley, are you there?
(audience cheering and applauding)
(upbeat music)
Stanley Tucci, everybody!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Oh my gosh!
First of all, what kind of art project
is happening behind you?
I'm into whatever is behind you.
What is that?
- I'm sitting in my studio
where I paint and write and things.
And this is part of
what happens in my mind.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I know that you've recently underwent
successful treatment for cancer.
So, God bless and how are you feeling?
- Thank you so much.
Thank you, yes. I feel,
I feel great.
I was very lucky.
The cancer I had was a very specific kind
and I had incredible
doctors out at Mount Sinai
in New York,
and the prognosis is great.
Thank you.
- Well, as a super fan,
I'm so happy to hear that, man.
(audience applauding)
You're such a talent.
I love everything you do, so.
Thank you for keeping our lunch date.
So what are we having today?
'Cause this looks delicious.
- Spaghetti
alla Zucchini,
- Okay.
- alla Nerano.
- Oh.
- So, it's basically
the simplest thing in the world.
It's spaghetti
with
sauteed, or sort of fried,
zucchini.
- [Kelly] Love it fried.
- [Stanley] And parmesana.
And it's a specialty of,
from the Amalfi Coast
and it is one of the most
delicious things I've ever had.
- Okay, well, I am pairing it with a glass
of Goldeneye Anderson Valley
Pinot Noir,
- [Stanley] Oh!
the go-to wine on "The
Kelly Clarkson Show".
- [Stanley] That is a great choice.
I think a Pinot Noir
- Thank you.
- is a perfect choice for that.
- I think Pinot Noir is a
perfect choice all the time.
Okay. (audience laughing)
(Stanley laughing)
So I'll just have a taste of that.
I don't know how to
eat spaghetti properly.
- [Stanley] Yeah.
- I cut it with a fork
and a knife.
Every Italian hates me across the world,
but whatever.
- [Stanley] Okay. Action!
- Oh my God!
That's really good!
(audience applauding)
- So simple.
It's like four ingredients.
- Oh my gosh.
So if we could have those
sent up to my room for lunch,
that's where I want that.
(Stanley laughing)
Yep. That's really good, man.
- Yeah.
- True, speaking of cooking,
is it true that you actually
cooked with Meryl Streep in her apartment
while making "Julie and Julia?"
- We did.
We cooked together
When we were about to start the film,
I asked her if,
we could cook together.
We had both finished shooting films prior,
and I knew she was busy
and tired, but I said,
"Not to be too method-y, but
could we just cook together?"
And we did and we had a great time.
We cooked one of Julia's recipes.
We cooked a Blanquette de Veau,
which is a sort of creamy veal dish,
and it ended up being delicious.
However, it was, we were too slow,
and we thought we were going
to serve dinner at eight,
we served it at 10.
(Kelly laughing)
- This is my problem with cooking, okay.
I can actually cook, but it
takes me like three hours
to do what it takes someone
like 30 minutes to 45 minutes.
I'm so slow 'cause I get nervous
and I triple check everything.
But that's like quite a recipe
- [Stanley] Yeah.
- to like,
be like, "Let's our first
time cooking together...",
you just jumped right into like
(laughing) a really hard recipe.
That's amazing!
- Yeah, (laughing) we did. And she,
she had made a Tarte Tatin based on
Julia's recipe that
was actually delicious.
- Wow! (audience giggling)
Well, it seemed that you
became even more famous,
if that's possible,
for making a drink during lockdown.
So what happened?
- Oh yes. Oh, there I am.
That's terrifying.
(audience laughing)
I made a drink.
- It's not terrifying,
it's sexy!
Yes!
- Is it?
- Making a drink
in all that black!
Get it! Get it, Stanley!
(audience cheering, applauding)
(Kelly giggling)
- Okay.
Well, thank you.
(Kelly giggling)
I don't know to respond.
(Stanley chuckling)
Yes, my wife Felicity asked me, she said,
"Would you make a drink for Curtis Brown?"
Which is the agency she
works, oh, there she is!
- Yeah!
- She said,
"Will you make a drink for the agency,
just a sort of in-house thing,
just to cheer people up
during the first lockdown?"
And I did. And then she said,
"Oh, well, let's put it on
the Instagram," you know,
which at the time had seven followers.
(Kelly laughing)
It's taken over my life
and I'm glad of it.
- It looked like a good drink, that's why.
Well, tell us about your new book.
It's called "Taste My Life Through
(stammering) Food".
I can't talk today.
(audience and Kelly giggling)
- No, that's okay.
That's, you know, Pinot Noir.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Here, here.
- I, yes, so I wrote this
book during lockdown.
I had written a cookbook
before with Felicity
and helped sort of curate one
that my parents had done many years ago.
But this is,
this is sort of literally
what the title is,
which is my life through food.
Because I realized that, at now,
at the age of 60, that my,
that everything that I seem to take in,
I take in either visually
or through my mouth.
(Kelly giggling)
And I experience the world
almost mostly through my mouth,
which sounds gross.
(audience laughing)
- It sounds like a really
naughty novel.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, I know. But Kelly, it's about,
that food is connected to every single,
part of my life.
It all revolves around
the most important aspect,
almost is,
what I eat,
and
how I share that with people.
- That's my favorite
part is how you share it.
That's what I love about a dinner,
everybody getting together
and it's always around food,
whether it's like a lunch
thing or a dinner party.
I love, that's my favorite thing,
is the mingling and all the people.
So that's, I love food as well.
(audience and Kelly giggling)
- It's the best way to make friends.
And it's the best way,
it's the best way to,
to find a common ground, I think.
- [Kelly] Amen.
(audience applauding)
Especially if it's great food.
Well, this was delicious, and I, no joke,
will be eating it for lunch.
Thank you. It was great to see you!
I love your art studio.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Take care, and thanks
for the zucchini pasta!